all right my battlefield 3 review just
in time for in charting free to come out
it is do this battlefield 3 alright so I
loved playing battlefield 2 so I was
like yeah obviously I'm getting
battlefield 3 and there are a couple of
aspects to review for battlefield 3 most
of which multiplayer some of which
single-player and as for the
single-player campaign at first I was
like it's pretty fun but I've seen this
kind of stuff in first-person shooters
before it follows a soldier named
Blackburn who's going after you know
terrorists and terrorist leaders and
weapons of mass destruction and it's a
showcase for some of the sweetest
graphics I've ever seen in a game ever
you're like this is some of the most
realistic lighting ever some people have
complained about some of the lens flares
because of the light and I just tell
them well just like in real life don't
look at the Sun how they unfold the
story is pretty cool this guy's getting
interrogated because he did something
that the US government doesn't like -
like you're an [ __ ] and where did you
go after that mission and he'll be like
alright well I went here and it'll play
that scenario so I thought that was
actually pretty cool
and it does a good job with getting you
familiar with some of the combat
elements you know sniper rifle jet
combat tank combat and ten combat you're
like dude I ain't God in jet combat
you're like I'm better than God I'm
maverick and goose from Top Gun
well goose anyway because you're sitting
in the back goose and in the
single-player campaign there are some
intense scenes or scenes where you're
running and crud is just blowing up
around you're like I am in war and this
is why I shouldn't be in war cuz I suck
and I die so if I ever get drafted into
the army I apologize to everybody let's
have a sniper rifle then I'll be like
Barry Pepper the Lord is my shepherd I
will fear no evil
and then the single-player campaign gets
really cool and then the story just ends
it's like it's over it ended which would
have disappointed me if I paid sixty
bucks for a single-player campaign but I
didn't battlefield 3 is a multiplayer
game don't let anyone tell you any
different as for the multiplayer how is
that it's awesome battlefield 3 some of
the funnest multiplayer you're ever
gonna play yeah 4 different classes to
choose from and the cool thing is you
level up those classes you unlock
weapons you unlock mods so the more you
play class the more stuff you're going
to get the more you're on a winning team
the more stuff you're gonna get so be
sure to be on a winning team play with
the Korean kids not against him yeah I
die a lot which is cool cuz I get to
find out exactly how much I suck at
first-person shooter games which means I
go to the default in first-person
shooters the sniper rifle that's my
go-to weapon very few things are more
gratifying in a first-person shooter
than when the guys running you have the
crosshairs just in front of them you
shoot the sniper rifle
nails them in the head you're like yeah
I am that badass the Lord is my shepherd
I will fear no evil till I find out
where I am and if someone puts a knife
in my medulla oblongata and kills me
still fun though this is my favorite
thing to do in Battlefield get me one
maybe two friends together just the
three of us are playing over only
playing sniper rifles we had the
straight-up sniper battle the matches
take like an hour each but it's so fun
dude you feel like you're in the movie
predator you're just like hunting people
you're like yeah but they're hunting me
T oh god then you hear a bullet whizzed
by your head you just freak out and run
dad or they find you in this stab a
knife in your medulla oblongata again so
the graphics the best around I'm telling
you this game looks sweet a
single-player campaign it is pretty fun
it has some really intense moments but
it doesn't really stand out from other
military base first-person shooters the
multiplayer is straight up the best
multiplayer you're going to find so if
you're a fan of multiplayer first-person
shooters get battlefield 3 what are you
waiting for
so your favorite first-person shooter
game doesn't have to be multiplayer just
first-person shooter what is it comment
below let me know mine probably doomed
to oh yeah I go old school like that
that was back when first-person shooter
games were you walking around taking on
an onslaught of enemies you flip a
switch walls come down there about 200
more enemies you got to take out I was
intense dude they don't make games like
that anymore but in the world where they
don't make games like that anymore
I'll take Battlefield 3's multiplayer in
any case if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]
you